hey guys it is friday before tape of
october my name's Jess and here's the
thing to metod in gaming this week I've
watched got a bunch of halloween items
this week as we suspected they might and
they're just as awesome as we hope the
100 new cosmetic items can be collected
from Halloween specifically fluxes and
you can check out all the gorgeous new
skins in our gallery on gamespot
alongside the new items is a PVE brawl
mode called junk and steins revenge
where four players take on zombie robots
and halloween themed versions of some of
the games heroes while defending atlas
from castle next up 2k and praxis have
confirmed that civilization 6 will
feature multiple heroes / civilization
in September it was revealed that
Pericles would be champion in Greece but
it's now been announced to the grease
can also be led by Gorgo who features
her own unique ability that grants a
culture bonus from killing or destroying
an enemy in combat she also has distinct
likes and dislikes praxis has explained
Gorgo seeks glory in combat therefore
she will never give up items in a peace
deal she prefers sibs who haven't
yielded in a peace deal and dislikes any
civ who's surrendered in a peace deal or
any service never engaged in a war
PlayStation fans have had to wait an
extra long time for rise of the Tomb
Raider to arrive but Sony have made a
pretty sweet throwback version the
PlayStation UK Twitter account has
revealed a fancy PlayStation 1 era CD
case for the tomb raider sequel the game
house inside is still a standard ps4
copy but there is a matching old school
manual along with it which is nice
unfortunately it doesn't appear as if
this version will be going on sale but
fingers crossed they might make more of
them following GTA Online's bikers
updated the game is now getting more
vehicles and British GTA online will now
include the demon custom motorcycle and
the Raptor which really needs to be seen
to be believed you can also grab this
fancy black western logo hoodie by
logging into GTA online
anytime between now and dr. burr 24
there are also a whole mess of discounts
in game and two new premium races right
now you can pop on and play forest a
non-contact bike race and then from
October 18 to 24 you can tuck into
double loop which can only be played
using supercars participating will help
you gain a ton of RP and cash you can
also now get a sixth property rock star
ancestors a much requested feature
because of course you need a six
property finally we cannot get this game
out of a new so I'm sorry in advance but
pokemon girl got an update here's the
latest two new features have been added
that include a new catch bonus system
and the tweak to gym training so now you
can bring six Pokemon into battle on top
of that you'll also now get egg and
incubator screens which periodically
update the distance you walk without the
need to close an open screen the update
has also made a number of fixes to
certain audio issues and the lengthy
evolution animation time you can check
out the full patch notes on gamespot
just make on-site I give you the lowdown
on what sweet female protagonists the
heading your way we compare battlefield
12 past Battlefield games and we break
down the awesome new Star Wars rook one
trailer that is everything a happy this
week so do let me know what matter to
you and Mary will be taking care of you
next week so you've got that to look
forward to I will see you again soon
you